une gerbe déposée sur les grilles de la
préfecture le monde de la nuit craint de
disparaître
gérant salarié ou simples amoureux des
pistes de danse
ils sont une quarantaine à tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé contrairement aux bars
et restaurants le public ne peut
toujours pas aller dans ces
établissements de nuit une mesure à
leurs yeux totalement injuste c'est un
loisir pour nous et une passion la danse
donc on est privé ça nous manque
énormément c'est notre sport habituel
ont fait pas confiance parce que là
l'heure actuelle nous empêcher de
travailler ou nourrir les discothèques
c'est repousser le problème ailleurs on
y voit bien tous les week-ends
effet les jeunes continuent faire la
fête pendant près d'une heure
une délégation est reçue par les
pouvoirs publics ces professionnels
espèrent rouvrir le rétablissement dès
le 11 juillet on clique on verra en
septembre
c'est ni plus ni moins qu'un pensable
intolérable ce qu'ont les femmes soldats
d'ouverture et en plus de ça on demande
à être indemnisées parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est ni plus ni moins qui abandonna la
traversée du désert s'annonce encore
longue pour les propriétaires de boîtes
de nuit lorsqu'il revient dans son
établissement
vide depuis quatre mois pascal ne cache
pas son désarroi
est ce que la clientèle voir revenir
donc c'est cette partie qui va être
compliqué on peut être y aura un
mouvement dans l'est dans les habitudes
mais bon toute façon le vrac les gens
s'amusent après c'est à nous de se
réorganiser de revoir un petit peu notre
copie voir comment on peut faire pour
attirer les clients toute façon c'est
après ça va nous remettre en question
en saône et loire une vingtaine
d'établissements et environ 200 salariés
en chômage partiel attendent maintenant
une réponse des pouvoirs publics
la balle est dans le camp du ministère
de l'intérieur